the fault line of a debate that
stretches across america and back
through decades
on both sides they know this moment is
central for the future of abortion all
over this country the consequences are
dire it could mean that in
up to half of the states here in the u.s
abortion could be banned or severely
restricted
there are arguments which touch on so
much murder is not a right you don't
have a right to murder people
it takes three to five days for that
baby to die religion drives the
anti-abortion movement and in huddles
they prayed
freedom and choice drives those who
believe it is a woman's right to choose
to me it is about autonomy it is about
women's rights to decide what to do with
their body we are the human beings here
not the
tiny little embryo that's the size of a
fingernail
we found contradiction and if the woman
has been raped or a victim of incest
we should kill the rapist not the baby
the baby didn't have any part in it
but nuance too sad i was pro-abortion
just a little over two years ago and the
reason i became pro-life was because i
was being sexually abused by an older
man who was over 18 years older than me
and it wasn't until i had a pregnancy
scare at 16 that i realized what i had
been advocating for was the exact same
violence that was committed against me
and it is the nine supreme court
justices on whose shoulders this now
rests in a court that is now 6-3
weighted towards conservatives they are
considering one case brought by one
abortion clinic in one state but it is
one which could prompt profound change
the supreme court wasn't obliged to take
this case the fact that the justices
have chosen to suggest that at the very
least they feel that the 1973 decision
to legalize abortion should be looked at
again they are put at a tremendously
greater risk
and so away from the cameras but with
audio allowed the justices and the
people listen to the arguments on both
sides
those two features story decisis and
termination of a human life your honor
puts all of those safely out of reach of
the court rules here
after a couple of hours pro-choice
lawyers had their assessment taking away
a constitutional right would really be
a tremendous step for the court to take
a constitutional right that women have
had for 50 years and i think the hor the
court heard us on that argument except
so many now believe that this court is
driven too much by politics the justices
will not rule on this for many months
but hints in their words suggest that
change could be coming mark stone sky
news at the u.s supreme court